bases are full
for gene segura
third past the diving davis down to the
corner one is in here comes harper he'll
score rounding third heading for home is
jt real muto and for the second time in
two weeks gene segora has a bases
clearing double and the phillies take a
three-nothing lead zach wheeler 4-0 the
2-2 era making his second start against
the mets after a great outing a couple
weeks ago
99 he overpowered him two outs here's
rhys hoskins in his last 12 games
hitting 320 with 13 rbis and 11 runs
scored 200 pitch
balls pulled
a two-run home run for reese hoskins
he's homer now in six of his last nine
games
uh the phillies take a five-nothing lead
with all two strikes
pitch
puts this ball on a rocket toward first
short hop scoop by smith in a slide
underhand flip to ramirez for the out at
first that is an outstanding play on the
ball that was hit nearly 104 miles an
hour toward him
pitch
swinging a line drive towards short leap
big catch by andres jimenez
that ball was scolded by gosselin at 109
miles an hour one ball two strikes
wheeler winds kicks and fires in the
pitch swung off missed he
got it
got a piece of it but it was caught by
romuto
toward the shift and a smothering play
by jimenez and he throws him out oh wow
andres jimenez putting on a defensive
dazzling display here today
36 pitches now 28 of them strikes for
zach wheeler as we start the fourth
football's the two strikes to smith
swinging the miss but after a high
fastball three strikeouts for wheeler
swing miss that wiped out
that's the fourth strikeout for wheeler
here at the top of the fifth inning jt
real muto
a 1-2 pitch
swinging a fly ball into right conforto
going back to the track looking up and
it is gone a home run to the opposite
field for jt real muto
his tenth of the year
and jt
extends the philly's lead it's now six
to nothing with that solo shot
that's ripped down the line by jimenez
and he's got himself an extra base hit
into the corner goes garlic jimenez will
pull in at second base with the lead-off
double and andres jimenez having himself
a day one ball two strikes
five strikeouts that one at 96 miles an
hour
now michael conforto who had an infield
hit in the first then struck out in the
third
[Applause]
and he lines one the other way for a
base in and that'll get the mets on the
board
amen has to score comporto heads for
second he's got an rbi double and it's
now six to one philadelphia
and davis drives one to right center
field that's down for a base sale
that'll bring in conforto and it'll go
to the wall
third double of the inning this one
belongs to jd davis he and conforto
trade places against philadelphia
and the mets have two runs home in the
fifth inning tom smith has more doubles
than anybody in the major leagues
and a first pitch curveball driven to
right garlic got turned around he can't
find it and it bounces up against the
wall in the score comes davis dives
around
fourth double of the inning it's now six
to three philadelphia
swing and a miss
strikeout number six for zach will
call strike three right on the outside
part of the plate seven strikeouts for
wheeler
ground ball out to second base segora is
up
and throws in time
line to center field and conforto's got
his third hit of the day
three hits yesterday three more hits
today for conforto was average up over
350. here's jd davis who doubled in a
run his last time up and he bangs one up
the middle that's a base hit
conforto stops at second as hazley picks
it up quickly
grounded down to first hoskins
gets the out at second gregorius's relay
thrown away and that's going to allow
one to score as conforto comes home and
now it's six to four
they had no chance to get canoe in first
base
gregorius made the throw anyway and on
the error conforto
[Music]
mcneil
[Applause]
and he crashes one out to right field
back goes harper to the warning track
[Applause]
[Music]
right center field segura around third
bottle by conforto segura will score
holding at third is nat he held late now
he's caught between third and home
girinos runs right into him and the
inning is over but the phillies have
tied it up at seven
and we'll bring saguaro up to the runner
at second base
there's a line drive out towards center
field on the run is nimmo he's not gonna
get it it's gone
a two-run home run for segora
and the phillies retake the lead
it's a 9-7 game here at the top of the
10th inning that was a bullets
so now it's nemo's one for five on the
day
and he slashes one through the hole for
a base egg that brings in jimenez to
make it a one-run game
davis
out to center field paisley on the run
on the track under it makes the catch
and the ball game is over and the
phillies win it in ten nine to eight
after squandering a six-run lead
[Applause]